Okay, willkommen zu unserer nächsten Episode von
Fellow Cast im Kontext des Moralpsychologie-
Workshops, den wir gestern
hier in Unique hatten. Können Sie uns sagen, wer Sie
sind und was Sie von Forschung in
diesem Kontext halten? Ich bin Maria Maman, ich bin
Postdoc  hier am Alaun Sie in der
Abteilung für Psychologie und ich bin
Entwicklungspsychologe, also arbeite ich
mit Kindern und hauptsächlich Vorschulkindern, also
ja, ich schaue mir an, wie Kinder
so gut ein Gefühl für Moral entwickeln, wenn sie
anfangen zu verstehen, was richtig und
was falsch ist und wie  Sie tauschen sich über
diese Dinge aus, also wie sie kommunizieren,
wenn sie zum Beispiel mit moralischen Urteilen konfrontiert werden,
wie sie ihre Entscheidung darüber treffen,
was richtig und falsch ist, wie sie
mit anderen über diese Dinge kommunizieren,
ja, das ist mein Hauptthema,
okay, und hast du einen Vortrag gehalten?  Ich habe
Sie gestern hier in München einen Vortrag gehalten.
Nein, habe ich nicht, werden Sie alles
geben  Ihrer Forschung okay,
so gut die Take-Home-Message für meine
Forschung ist, dass ich denke, dass es nicht ausreicht,
wenn wir wissen wollen, wie Menschen
zu einem moralischen Urteil kommen, also das Urteil,
ob etwas richtig oder falsch ist,
sie einfach danach zu fragen  Sie
denken, dass Helfen gut oder schlecht ist, aber
dass es in der Forschung wichtig ist, ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
wie Menschen zu ihren
Urteilen kommen. Ja, wenn Sie also eine Geschichte über jemanden sehen, der
jemandem hilft, und Sie
dann fragen, was Sie davon halten, was die
Geschichte tatsächlich bringen soll  Menschen, miteinander zu reden,
um ihre Ideen auszutauschen,
warum sie denken, dass etwas richtig und
etwas falsch ist, und deshalb denke ich,
dass wir in der Interaktion mit anderen unsere moralischen Fähigkeiten
und unser Gefühl für
moralisches Denken am besten einsetzen, anstatt nur zu
zeigen  es was richtig und was
falsch ist
yeah Kumpel könnte es sein, dass der
Grund dafür in einer Diskussion liegt, dass man
sich mehr in die Situation einbezogen fühlt, als
wenn man nur eine Frage auf einem
Blatt Papier beantwortet  Ja, ich denke schon, also ich denke
, wenn Sie einen Gesprächspartner haben, müssen Sie
Ihre Gründe für Ihre Urteile tatsächlich zum Ausdruck bringen, und
normalerweise meine ich, wenn es darum geht, ob
Helfen richtig oder falsch ist, sind wir normalerweise nicht
anderer Meinung, aber sobald Sie  Sie
stehen vor einer Art moralischem Dilemma,
in dem Sie entweder helfen oder
etwas anderes tun könnten, das moralisch relevant ist,
also zum Beispiel ein Versprechen halten,
etwas zu tun, und von jemandem abgelenkt werden,
der Hilfe braucht, dann was das
Richtige ist  diese Situation und
so, wenn ich mir einfach meine eigene Meinung entscheide und
dann sage, oh, ich denke, Sie sollten helfen
, das geht nicht, aber wenn ich, wenn ich
einen Gesprächspartner habe, ist es notwendig,
tatsächlich auszudrücken, warum ich denke, na ja, wissen Sie
Ich denke, Versprechen einzuhalten ist
auch wichtig, aber auf der anderen Seite
gibt es jemanden, der Hilfe braucht,
also drücke ich meine Gedankengänge aus,
wenn Sie sagen möchten, und meine Gründe für
ihre Urteile, die
ich eigentlich denke, besonders wenn Sie
Die Arbeit mit Kindern macht es auch einfacher zu
verstehen, wie sie über Dinge denken,
denn bei Kindern kann es auch vorkommen,
dass sie einfach denken, dass Helfen
wichtiger ist, weil die Farbe des
Kleides der Person, die Hilfe braucht, besser
gefällt, wissen Sie, wie diese Gründe können  Seien Sie auch dort
und wir werden es nicht wissen, wenn wir uns nur
Urteile und nicht die
Entscheidungsprozesse ansehen. Ja,
Sie arbeiten hauptsächlich und wie Sie
hauptsächlich in der Psychologie arbeiten. Ich denke,
Sie hatten Recht in Ihrem
Hintergrund  hatte auch andere
Disziplinen da könntest du gerne mal
reinschauen wie bist du auch von anderen
Dingen beeinflusst ja also ich studiere eigentlich
Linguistik und
hab dann am Max-Planck-
Institut für evolutionäre Anthropologie
in Leipzig promoviert und da war das wirklich
Die Leute kamen aus wirklich unterschiedlichen
Hintergründen, also hatten wir natürlich viele
Psychologie-Leute, aber sie waren auch
Philosophen und Biologen und
Erziehungswissenschaftler und so
gab es eine  wirklich
interdisziplinärer Haufen und ich habe eigentlich
auch einige der
Konferenzen der Gesellschaft für
Philosophie und Psychologie ZAR besucht
, der Austausch mit
Philosophen hat mir immer irgendwie gefallen und auch während
meines Studiums habe ich
einige Sprachphilosophie- und Sprachaufsätze gelesen
Ja, ich denke, dass es zumindest für mich wirklich wichtig ist, mich
auch aus anderen Bereichen zu informieren, um
tatsächlich eine Vorstellung davon zu bekommen, was
in meinem Bereich relevante Fragen sind und was
aktuelle oder auch alte Ideen sind, wie man
Dinge angehen soll, und so ich  Denken Sie,
dass dies zumindest im Hinterkopf behalten wird, dass
es andere Disziplinen als die Psychologie gibt
, die für Ihre eigene Forschung sehr hilfreich sind,
und was das Ziel Ihres
zukünftigen Studiums ist. Wie gesagt,
ich arbeite wirklich am interaktiven Prozess
des moralischen Denkens und  Ich interessiere mich wirklich
dafür, wie Kinder lernen,
was richtig und falsch ist, und wie sie
ihre Welt verstehen können, und ich denke, dass
viele dieser Dinge eine Rolle spielen  ppen in den
Interaktionen mit Eltern und so habe ich
bereits eine kleine Studie über die
Mutter-Kind-Interaktion gemacht und jetzt möchte ich
das ein wenig ausweiten, und auch
weil ich denke, dass Elternschaft
stark von der Kultur beeinflusst wird, werde ich das
kulturübergreifend betrachten und auch betrachten  Andere
Einflüsse wie das erste Land
bedeuten nicht unbedingt, dass Sie ins Ausland gehen müssen,
aber es könnte auch bedeuten, dass Sie sich einfach
andere Kontexte und kulturelle Maßstäbe ansehen,
wenn Sie es so sagen wollen,
denn in der Psychologie ist die Stichprobe, die Sie
haben, wirklich oft in Richtung Gleiches voreingenommen
hochgebildete und
so westliche Familien, und ich denke, es macht
besonders in diesem Bereich Sinn, aber
es geht um die Werte, die Sie haben und die Sie
Ihren Kindern vermitteln möchten,
um den Horizont wirklich zu erweitern und sich
alle verschiedenen Familien anzusehen und wie sie
ihre Werte vermitteln  welche
Art von Werten sie haben und all diese
Dinge, an denen ich wirklich interessiert bin, das
klingt wirklich interessant, und die
Hauptfrage wäre, wie moralisch
Urteilsvermögen wird in gewisser Weise von Eltern in der Erziehung entwickelt,
ja, also, wie gehen
Eltern mit ihren Kindern um, wenn es
um moralische Themen geht, okay, ja, im
Grunde, ob sie zum Beispiel
Eltern haben können, die wirklich
egalitärer sind und sagen, was Sie tun
Denken Sie über die Situation wie dieses
Dilemma nach, ja, also reden Sie mit ihrem
Vier- oder Sechsjährigen,
also was denken Sie, wie machen Sie daraus einen
Sinn und versuchen, es
aus der Perspektive der Kinder aufzubauen und das
wirklich einzubeziehen und  Sie haben vielleicht
Eltern, die denken, dass ich eigentlich derjenige bin,
der weiß, was richtig und falsch ist, also
werde ich meinem Kind beibringen, wie man es macht, und
das ist wirklich eine andere
Art von Interaktion, richtig, und ich möchte die
Unterschiede sehen und vielleicht auch  Woher diese
Unterschiede kommen und wie sich diese
Unterschiede in
das Verhalten von Kindern, eigentlich moralisches
Verhalten, übersetzen. Haben Sie einen Satz, was wir tun sollten,
oder was könnte so ähnlich sein
? Eine Schlussfolgerung Ihrer Forschung, ja ja  ah
okay also ein normativ hast du einen
normativen satz für für uns oder eine vermutung
wie wir moralische urteile in der
interaktion bilden sollten okay du kannst meine
frage genauer spezifizieren wenn du magst also okay ich
denke das ist man als erwachsener wirklich
gewöhnt oder  wie zumindest auch als
gebildeter Erwachsener als Student und man es
gewohnt ist - Urteile zu fällen,
wenn man sich nicht sicher ist, was man tun soll -
eigentlich ist es
Gründe zu finden, Vor- und Nachteile zu finden, Vor- und Nachteile zu kennen,
Vor- und Nachteile aufzulisten und aber das ist es  auch
in einem dialog weißt du wie du darüber
nachdenkst welche gründe
ich dafür und dafür vorbringen kann und oft
wenn man diese ideen einfach austauscht und
man unterschiedliche perspektiven bekommt dann denke ich
mir das urteil was richtig ist
was zu tun ist  und ich denke,
wir alle kennen alltägliche moralische Dilemmata, du
weißt, ob ich einem Freund
wegen dieser anderen Sache, die ich tun wollte, oder so
etwas absagen sollte, ja, und wenn du
entweder an jemand anderen denkst, mit dem du
reden kannst, werde ich tatsächlich mit jemandem reden
und zu einem mobilen Urteilsvermögen zu gelangen, und das ist
tatsächlich etwas, das ich denke, ist hilfreich,
okay, also kultiviere deinen inneren Dialog,
um vielleicht in deinem moralischen Urteilsvermögen zu wachsen
Videos sind in der Beschreibung Vielen Dank
fürs Ansehen und bis zum nächsten Mal mit
anderen Darstellern auf Wiedersehen